today on the matt walsh show more
information has come out about what
could quite possibly be the biggest
scandal in history and yet it's treated
as a minor sideshow at best also camilla
harris thoroughly embed embarrasses
herself on camera we're used to that by
now but this one is pretty bad even by
her standards and an australian
politician puts out what is accidentally
the most racist video you will ever see
it also happens to be totally hilarious
and a doctor brags publicly about
refusing to take her injured son to the
doctor for fear of covet finally in our
daily cancellation i will go toe-to-toe
with every anti-johnny the walrus video
on youtube there are a bunch of them and
we're canceling all of them today on the
matte wall show
[Music]
you know the pro-life movement must
maintain its momentum now more than ever
and what better way to help than by
supporting the charities and causes that
you care about even if the supreme court
were to strike down roe v wade abortion
will still exist in america across the
country charity mobile is the pro-life
phone company they partner with you to
automatically support the pro-life
pro-family charities of your choice with
five percent of your monthly plan price
and they've sent millions of dollars to
charities so far and they're going to
send millions more this year new
activations and eligible accounts get a
free cell phone with free activation and
free shipping when you mention offer
code walsh certain restrictions apply
charity mobile makes makes it easy to
switch you could just keep your existing
phone number and you might even be able
to keep your existing phone all of their
monthly plans include unlimited domestic
minutes and messages which can be shared
by up to eight lines on a family plan
there are no contracts or no termination
fees and there's no risk with their
30-day guarantee great live customer
support and a great nationwide coverage
on america's most reliable network you
get all of that if you switch to charity
mobile and support the causes you care
about call them at 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com and mention offer code
walsh
so one of the consequences of living in
a civilization gone mad is that our
collective priorities tend to be out of
balance and confused reflecting in
general the state of things it doesn't
help that we're bombarded with a
never-ending onslaught of information
misinformation disinformation it's hard
to follow one particular ball when there
are a million being thrown at you all at
once every day forever and always the
result is that some of the most
important stories of our time are either
ignored
or treated as merely one bouncing ball
among many and often there are very
powerful forces working to ensure that
we don't spend too much time focusing on
it
that brings us to the story of kovid's
origins
how it was formed
how it ended up in the population
and the apparently global cover-up
designed to distract from these
questions and obscure the answers
it all amounts to quite easily one of
the greatest scandals in the history of
the world that's not an exaggeration
perhaps in fact the greatest scandal
yet it's hardly discussed
and nobody not one person anywhere has
been held accountable for it
the truth is out there as they say the
information is available but nothing
comes from it
one of history's great scandals and it
lands with a thud and a yawn somehow
so here's the latest more details that
that should be breaking news everywhere
reported with big screaming headlines
but instead it's been largely ignored
except for for some outlets including
the blaze which reports this quote
new information from previously redacted
emails confirms that scientists
consulting with government officials
believed that the covet 19 lab league
origins hypothesis was not only possible
but perhaps even likely before dr
anthony fauci and dr francis collins
worked to denounce the theory as a
conspiracy
in a letter to the head of the
department of health and human services
house judiciary committee ranking member
uh representative jim jordan and
committee on oversight reform ranking
members uh representative james comer
revealed the text of redacted emails
from february 2020. that's february 2020
very back way at the beginning
in which prominent public health
scientists discussed the origin of covet
19 with fouchy and collins
okay now we already knew from previously
released emails
that many of the leading scientists
virologists epidemiologists in the world
suspected early on that this virus was
engineered in a chinese lab now that was
also obvious to any common sense person
based simply on the fact that it came
out of wuhan
right where a virus lab happened to be
situated
now that's not conclusive proof in and
of itself
but uh if you see smoke
and then you also see fire it probably
is safe to assume that the smoke is
coming from the fire but the scientists
who looked at this had more than just
common sense assumptions to go on they
inspected the virus itself and they
could tell based on its features
that it probably didn't come from a bowl
of bat soup
yet many of these very same scientists
changed their tune
rather suddenly and began denouncing the
lab leak theory that they themselves had
speculated about
now we already knew all of that now we
get to the newest revelations
uh quote the new details reveal that dr
fauci was warned of two things
one the potential that kova 19 leaked
from the wuhan institute of virology and
two the possibility that the virus was
intentionally genetically manipulated
lawmakers wrote according to the
transcripts released by gop staff both
collins the former director of the
national institute of health
of health and fouchy the current
director of the national institute of
allergy and infectious diseases we're
told by prominent scientists that the
lab leak origin of cover 19 was
scientifically plausible
now there are a bunch of emails but one
of the most important is from a guy
named dr jeremy farrar to fauci francis
collins and another nih official named
lawrence tabik
and this is summarizing a conference
call involving all of these men
the blaze says quote
ferrar noted that dr michael farzan a
scripps research professor of immunology
and the discoverer of sars receptor was
quote bothered by the furin site and has
a hard time explaining
that as an event outside the lab the
furan site is part of the cell and i
mean it's scientific stuff i don't
understand i don't need to understand it
uh it says the email is referring to the
firs the furin cleavage site of the uh
cover 19 virus spike protein a unique
feature of the virus that makes it
infectious
he said that this evidence means it's
highly unlikely that the virus developed
naturally
a different scientist on the same call a
microbiologist
said that there was quote no plausible
natural scenario
no plausible natural scenario for this
virus to go from bats to humans
and yet
as the blaze reports quote regardless of
these arguments
collins wrote back to farrar faucia and
tabik later that day
that he was quote coming around to the
view that a natural origin is more
likely
appearing to agree with arguments
presented by ron fochier a dutch
scientist that famously authored a
controversial gain of function study and
christian drostin
germany's leading covenanting expert
fochier in a february second email
thanking conference called participants
for having the meeting referred to the
lab league hypothesis as a conspiracy
theory
and said it would quote need to be
supported by strong data beyond a
reasonable doubt
quote it's good that this possibility
was discussed in detail with a team of
experts however further debate about
such accusations would unnecessarily
distract top researchers from their
active duties and do unnecessary harm to
science in general and science in china
in particular
collins said that he agreed with
farrar's view that quote a swift
convening of experts in a confidence
inspiring framework is needed or the
voices of conspiracy will quickly
dominate doing great potential harm to
science and to international harmony
wait do harm to science what does that
mean
science is a process for understanding
the natural world
how can it be harmed
and especially how can the truth harm it
saying that the truth harms science it's
like saying love harms a marriage
it makes no sense and as for damaging
international harmony
one might think that the damage to
international harmony was done by the
country that released a virus onto the
globe that killed millions of people
at any rate collins and voucher continue
to discuss ways to suppress the lab leak
hypothesis a hypothesis that they knew
was at the very least plausible
they both went on publicly to denounce
it as a crazy possibly racist conspiracy
theory
the corporate media picked up this line
as did many high-ranking elected
democrats social media platforms started
banning accounts that mention the
possibility that the virus came from a
lab
all of this happened even though as we
know now
some of the the leading scientists in
the world scientists that fouchu worked
with
knew from the beginning
that it likely came from a lab
so there was we know now a conspiracy to
cover this up fauci and collins ran
cover for the chinese government
and they had a lot of help in that
effort
so to review and recap the most
plausible version of events based on the
information currently available to us
is that
a virus was engineered in a chinese lab
it left the lab i mean we talked about
lab leak and that assumes that it was
done accidentally
we certainly don't know that
whether accidentally or intentionally it
left the lab
many millions of people died as a result
meanwhile our public health authorities
conspired to suppress the truth of its
origin
and defame and slander anyone who spoke
up about it
and censor and to platform them
um this is like this is uh
this is chernobyl times a thousand
in another world at another time
this would all be treated as the biggest
story on the planet
the media report would report on it
every single day there would be hearings
and trials and tribunals
fauci would already be under arrest
china would be the subject of a global
investigative effort to figure out
exactly what it did and why it did it
they would face reprisals and
punishments for killing five million
people
there'd be something like the nuremberg
trials happening right now instead
nobody's held accountable for anything
and our biggest concern with respect to
china is ensuring that nobody says
anything that might provide uh uh you
know provoke anti-asian sentiment
this is not a serious time and we are
not a serious country
but it's a serious scandal maybe the
most serious
ever in history
despite how it's treated
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know we all have favorite photos
from vacations family events even uh a
cranky sob like myself i even have
pictures that i cherish and why not take
those and turn those into beautiful
works of art if you want to truly give a
meaningful gift you've got to try
paintyourlife.com get a professional
hand-painted portrait created from any
photo at a truly affordable price or
combine photos of people or places that
you love into one painting so you can
make your own sort of unique new um
scene from that choose from a team of
world-class artists and work with them
until every detail is perfect their
user-friendly platform makes it easy to
order a custom-made hand-painted
portrait in less than five minutes very
quick very easy and
it's also you you get the the final
result back very quickly as well you can
receive your portrait in as little as
two weeks um and i can also tell you
it's a very hands-on experience
throughout they're always asking for
your feedback as the painting progresses
and so you have control the entire way
through
very responsive very easy at
paintyourlife.com there's no risk if you
don't love the final painting your money
is refunded guaranteed and right now is
a limited time offer get 20 off your
painting that's right 20 off and free
shipping to get this special offer text
the word matt to 64 000 that's matt to
64 000 text matt to 64 000 paint your
life celebrate the moments that matter
most
terms apply available at
paintyourlife.com terms again text matt
to 64 000.
so i want to jump in right away with
this uh because it is simply fantastic
really it's one of my favorite videos
of all time this kind of brilliant
comedy
is what you might have gotten from a
comedy show like snl back when comedy
was still legal now we have to settle
for getting our comedy from real life
so um so here is western australian
premier mark mcgowan he has uh recorded
a video where he's trying to communicate
some basic things about about covid to
the aboriginal community in the area
and so he's decided to to begin with
speak very very slowly
using using small words so that they can
understand him
but he's even hired an aboriginal elder
to translate for him in real time
and the results are
truly extraordinary let's watch
important message to keep aboriginal
people safe
and legion message
a proper important one to keep everybody
safe one
you can die from the corona or get
really sick
you will again
pass away
from this groaner
or you better get really sick one
it's time to get the corona needle to
keep people and country strong
djinn
he timed to give him this needle
longer corona
to keep him but all the people
and country proper strong one
the corona needle will protect kids old
people
men and women
well
the uncrowned needle
gonna keep
mail a safe one for all our kids
and for all the men and women
okay many people around the world um
sorry uh i didn't understand any of that
i need it translated into american
english
we need a third translator there
actually i i did it understand it in
fact i um i guess the big news here is i
learned just now that i speak aboriginal
australian so i i am bilingual that's uh
that's good news
why not just have her if you're gonna do
this
which you shouldn't in the first place
but why not just have her alone
giving this address
if you really feel that it's necessary
like why do you need to be in the video
too
you can tell that she's actually having
trouble saying it differently
so that's that's where she's struggling
as a translator
usually i guess the challenge is to you
know translate it correctly but um in
this case she's like looking at the
words and she's trying to think how am i
supposed to say it differently from what
you already just said
so she just puts the word one after
everything she says
um but so if you're gonna do it just
have her alone
better yet
uh don't do it at all
because this is
this is truly racist by definition and
and i i hate to uh to engage in the
whole
the left or the real racist thing
but but actually they are
right i mean it's true
it's true because the definition of
racism
is um and it does have an actual
definition
it's got nothing to do with what we hear
the critical race theory proponents it's
power plus privilege and all that's got
nothing to do with any of that
racism is actually a very simple thing
racism is
the belief
that a certain race of people are
inferior to you
because of their race
so it's not even a belief that an
individual person of another race is
inferior to you
that could be a rude thing to think or
say
um
but it's the belief that an entire race
because of the race are inferior to
yourself that's racism
like anything else there are a lot of
other
things that you can think and things you
could say that are rude and not nice
but aren't racist that's what racism is
and so we see how in in fact really the
left actually are the real races because
this is how they feel
this guy what's this guy's name again
mark mcgowan
he he looks at the aboriginal people as
clearly like children
and so rather than speaking to them like
adults and saying what he would say to
everybody else
is to slow down
i mean they speak english that's the
point here but he's got to slow down use
very small words
and then have someone next to him
translating it
into sort of a colloquial vernacular
that is you believe that they're
inferior to you
and this is what we always get from the
left
um
from these white knight white leftists
they think that um that other races they
they take this paternalistic pose
and they treat other races as though
they're all a bunch of children
whereas the the non-racist
point of view
is to say is to just hold everyone to
the same standard
have the same expectations for everybody
i don't care what race you are i mean if
we all speak english you should be able
to understand english
even if it's not in the in in your we
all have our own colloquial kind of way
of speaking but you should be able to
understand english that isn't that isn't
uh couched in your own colloquial
language
or vernacular
that's the expectation i have for
everybody
that's why i'm against affirmative
action say hold up have the same
expectation for everybody hold everyone
to the same standard i don't care what
race you are
here's the standard here's what we're
looking for based on the merits
and whatever race you are there's no
reason why you can't
um
live up to that there's no reason why
you can't get over that bar and if you
can't then you don't deserve to get
hired for the position or to go to that
school or whatever it is
so this is if you're a white leftist i
mean it's really uh uh
for
not
members of the other race uh you do take
a paternalistic view they're inferior to
you
and then members of your own race you
hate them also
so it's just it's just racism and hatred
and
resentment
sprayed in all directions towards
everybody
all right let's move to camila harris on
nbc here she is a couple couple clips
here before we get to the to the really
good one we'll start with this
talking about how to find tests
um
and she has an interesting response to
that let's listen
two years into this
why did the administration just go out
and and secure
more at-home tests after the delta
search in the fall why are we at a point
now where folks still can't get tests
but we just ordered
a
i don't have the number in front of me
but millions of tests we have 20 000
sites where people can go and i urge
people to you can google it or go on to
any search engine and find out where
free testing and the free testing site
is available but not a vice president
the fact that we're still telling people
to google where you can get a test
but oh but come on now i mean really if
you if you want to figure out how to get
across town to some restaurant you heard
is great you usually do google to figure
out where it is so that's simply about
giving people
right a mechanism by which they can
locate something that they need
something that can help them
did she just say do google
you know you got to do it do the do
google
plug it into on the internets you do the
google
what is with she seems to have picked
this up from biden i don't know what it
is with the biome but this is like
infectious i guess where where she does
this thing now too or her primary
argument is come on
i mean come on now come on
of course the answer that she should be
giving to this line of questioning about
tess is that look we don't need uh to
have 100 million tests out there
because if you're not sick you don't
need to be getting tests the whole
reason we're running out of tests this
this is one where i don't i don't blame
i actually don't blame the body
administration for this
the fact that there's
some places are running the reason why
some places are running out of tests is
that you got all these these psychotic
people who are hoarding tests when
they're not even sick
that's why we're running out as long as
people are doing that we're going to run
out of tests
but what you should say is it doesn't
matter you don't need a test if you're
not sick live your life
if you are sick stay home
if you have a heat if you have a fever
or whatever that just stay home like you
would any other time
what do you need to test for
that's what she should say but she she
can't say that
uh because she cannot abandon
the course and abandon this strategy and
speaking of the strategy she was also
asked um
is is the strategy working
i mean we're looking at record levels of
of uh coveted cases right now
doesn't seem to be much indication that
the biden administration strategy is
working so is it time to change course
she's asked and here's what she says
at what point does the administration
say you know what this strategy isn't
working we're going to change strategies
six former
administration officials last week wrote
that open letter urging the
administration to change course to
change strategy
is it time
it is time for us to
do what we have been doing and that time
is every day
every day it is time for us to agree
that
there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
my god
i so direct transcript here okay
um
i had trouble i feel like i need the
aboriginal translator for that one
actually that was that was that's this
is tough to understand
so here's what she said direct
transcript verbatim
it's time for us to do what we have been
doing and that time is every day
let's pause on that sentence just for a
second it's time for us to do what we
have been doing
and that time is every day well i okay
so i guess
in a way that makes sense so
whatever we're doing right now
it's it's time for us to be doing that
and so like whatever you're i'm trying
to understand this whatever you're doing
in the present moment
well it's obviously time that you're
doing that and so that time is every day
because you're always living in the
present moment so whatever you're doing
in that moment that's what you're doing
in that moment and that time is every
day all the time
that makes sense no it doesn't make any
sense at all it doesn't uh then she says
okay so it's time for us to do what we
have been doing and that time is every
day every day it is time for us to agree
that there are things and tools that are
available to us to slow this thing down
the only part of that that sort of made
sense
from her perspective is every day it's
time for us to agree that's really what
she wanted to get to ev you know what
it's time for every day from just agree
with me that's what it's time for
she is so bad at this
she is terrible at this
um
probably the least skilled politician
we've seen at this level
certainly in our lifetimes
i mean there's a reason why democrats
are now thinking about pulling
hillary clinton out of her crypt
i thought she was the least talented
politician
camilla harris makes makes hillary
clinton look
human by comparison makes hillary
clinton look charismatic
and skilled by comparison
she's really making me think that i
could why don't i just run at this point
i always thought no i could never run
for political office because number one
that sounds like
hell on earth to be in that position
it's a lot more fun to complain about
politicians than to be one of them but
also i know that i would be terrible at
it
um
but i'd be better than this at least
wow
uh okay moving now to i just wanna
one clip here we've got
members of the republican establishment
after this speech yesterday from biden
uh in
georgia where he said that everyone who
disagrees with him is a confederate and
a racist uh they're all you know and
and he and biden said that after
claiming when he got into office that he
wanted to united everybody so uh
republican establishment they're very
upset about this
they feel backstabbed
because they've been pretty supportive
of biden they haven't been too critical
of him
um
some of them supported him over trump
and so they thought that that they would
always be the exception
and they thought at the very least when
biden delivers a speech like this he
would say that my opponents are all
racist uh except for except for these
guys over here they're fine
and the republican establishment is
shocked and appalled to find out that
didn't happen
they're getting lumped in with everybody
else
so here's mitt romney uh expressing his
uh his his shock and horror
some remarks to uh to give this evening
um
but i uh had the occasion to watch
president biden
as he spoke in georgia just a few
minutes ago
and he said quite a number of things
that simply weren't true
he also accused a number of my good and
principled colleagues in the senate of
having sinister even
racist inclinations
he charged that voting against his bill
allies us
with bull connor george wallace
and jefferson davis
so much for unifying the country
and working across the aisle
more troubling however
he said that the goal of some
republicans
is to quote turn the will of the voters
into a mere suggestion
and so president biden goes down the
same tragic road taken by president
trump
casting doubt on the reliability of
american elections
this is a sad
sad day
i expected more
of president biden
you did what does that tell you what
does that tell you about what does that
tell us about you rather i should say
that you expected more why did you
expect more president biden
what has he ever shown you in his he's
been in the public eye for 97 years what
is in in in those the nearly century
that he's been
uh
on the stage
what has he ever shown you ever that
would make you expect more
but mitt romney totally scandalized by
this can't believe it uh well also mitch
mcconnell also was was very very upset
nearly in in tears
that uh that he had been accused of
racism in this way by a man who he he
was he's just disappointed he expected
more
let's listen
yesterday
that very same man delivered a
deliberately
divisive
speech
that was designed to pull our country
further
apart
12 months ago this president said we
should see each other not as adversaries
but his neighbors
yesterday
he called
millions of americans
his domestic
enemies
who would have thought
he said he wanted to bring us all
together turns out he didn't want to do
that
these these people will never learn
you know as i've tried to explain many
times
nobody
wants unity actually
least of all joe biden
because unity for unity's sake can't
exist you got to unite around something
there have to be sort of like terms
upon which we are
within which we are we are uniting
and so the terms of unity for joe biden
are that you do exactly as he says
and um you submit
and then and then we can all have unity
there we can have unity in in chains we
can have unity in in submission
in obedience to him
that's what he means by unity just to
clarify for you
um all right this tweet from a doctor
this is dr tatiana prowl and it looks at
first like a joke some sort of
dark parody but but it's actually not
and it maybe is the perfect summation of
uh of everything that's wrong with our
society's coveted response
so tatiana pral md verified account on
twitter so you know she's really
important
she says in case it helps to be concrete
my teen my teen missed a step and rolled
his ankle badly last night
in usual times we'd go to his
pediatrician or urgent care and get an
x-ray nope
we'll sort it out when omicron settles
we have no confidence that healthcare
settings are safe right now
and you can see a picture of the guys
the kids like the kid's ankle
and a lot of discoloration i'm not a
doctor myself she's supposedly a doctor
a lot of discoloration there a lot of
swelling
could be could be a sprained ankle it
could be a broken foot also
that's what it looks to me
but she's going to let her kid and she's
bragging about this
eventually she took the tweet down she
put her account on private and
everything because she was uh
people were reacting to it by saying oh
you're you're neglecting and abusing
your child cps need to someone needs to
make a call to cps here
this is this is
abuse and neglect this is what medical
neglect of a child looks like
but at first anyway she was proud of it
and she thought that she would get
nothing but a pat on the back and
applause
that she's taking kovid seriously
because that's all that matters just
take covert seriously that's that's the
only
medical thing that matters
that's the only threat that any of us
face is coven
even omicron which is uh or omnicorn
apologist which is nothing but a cold
for almost everybody
and so she's going to let her child
suffer
no x-ray and just i guess hopefully give
him some tylenol
and yeah well she says we'll sort it out
when uh omnicorn goes away so you know
next month two months three months we'll
sort it out then
if he's permanently disfigured by now if
he's got a bone that was broken and and
heals the wrong way and he's got like a
bent foot now well you know
at least he didn't catch a cold
but she's going to do all of this of
course as always for herself not for her
kid
because she's afraid to take the kid to
the doctor then she gets sick she
doesn't want him to pick something up
and then give it to her
and we see how the priorities are
totally flipped around here
that covid is the number one threat that
everyone faces and for this kid like
right now the biggest threat that he
faces medically is that potentially
broken bone that he has
that's not getting treatment
all right moving on i gotta i have to
show you this uh also we won't play much
of it but i saw it now you have to see
you know what the rules are uh on this
show if i'm subjected to it then i've
got to pass the misery along
uh so let's play we'll play just uh i'll
give you 30 seconds of this
i think that's enough to prove the point
go ahead
you're gonna get corona from mona don't
vaccinate don't wait don't hesitate you
gotta vaccinate in the lonesome state
vaccination is so great vaccinate me all
day long vaccinate yo daddy my vaccinate
my body facts you need me at the party i
vaccine dream i love the vaccine all day
long i want to vaccinate your mom i want
to stick
in your arm oh my where are you
uh not a bad song actually you could
tell you put a lot of people a lot of
work into that and he memorized it and
everything
i don't know i don't know the context
there i don't know where that happened i
don't i don't know why i don't know what
enough drugs this guy's on
doesn't matter he's on the vaccine at
the very least
and that's it
you you saw it now all right this is the
new york post uh important news here
um
this husband and wife improved their
i should have read this article ahead of
time oh i'm just gonna read the first
this is a new york post this is the
first sentence of the article it says
this husband and wife improved their
boom boom by sleeping in separate
bedrooms
this made it past an editor at a major
news publication
uh it uses the term boom boom to
refer to sexual relations anyway terry
anne michelle and mary mother of three
unwittingly sparked a now viral social
media conference controversy after
revealing that she and her husband jamie
improved their sex life by sleeping in
different beds in different rooms of
their house
michelle told the post our lovemaking is
actually better because we're both
getting better sleep and it puts us in
better moods
and we've made it more exciting by
coming up with fun ways to be intimate
afterwards we're like okay it's time for
bed and we sleep in our separate rooms
she added noting that they do share
their master suite on weekends
michelle a hairdresser and a
stay-at-home mom who lives in a
six-bedroom house in ontario canada
briefed her over 20 000 tick-tock
followers of her bizarre arrangements on
tuesday and um this is what she said she
sleeps in different different rooms
experts agree
so there are experts on this subject of
sleeping arrangements for couples people
that are apparently experts we're
supposed to go to experts agree that a
bedroom breakup can profoundly enhance a
pair's romance
uh quote choosing to sleep in separate
beds and even separate rooms in order to
increase the quality and frequency of
great sleep is a wonderful way to
enhance your sex life because it also
puts a big emphasis on your own physical
health sex and relationship expert
viviana coles explained to the post and
anything that you can do to increase and
improve your physical health enhances
your sexual health you know i want to
know first of all is um
anytime i hear about
sex and relationship experts i want to
know your own marital history
that's that's what we should know i
don't care about i don't care where you
went to school i don't care at all about
your academic resume
i want to know
if you're a relationship expert
are you married
and uh do you have kids
and how long have you been married
you're not in the running to be a
relationship expert if you're not at
least married so that that rules you out
if you're not married
you haven't gotten to like the the sort
of the finish line
um
of the the opening stages of
relationship and actually and actually
tied the knot then you're not a
relationship expert
um if you've been married for
certainly
less than a decade
you're not in the running to be a
relationship expert and if you don't
have kids
you're also not a relationship expert
because that's when that's when the
relationship is really tried by fire is
when you have kids
and there are all kinds of challenges
that you meet in your relationship that
relate to having kids that if you've
never been through that then you're you
can't possibly be an expert
and then even if you have
crossed that entire gauntlet
i'm not sure that you're still not a
relationship expert you maybe have some
expertise in your own relationship
but as far as other people's i'm not
sure what you really have to offer
um
here's what i will say as someone who at
least i am married i've been married for
10 years and i have kids
so you can notice i
you know i kind of i kind of set this up
so that uh
i qualify as a relationship expert that
all happens to be a coincidence
um as far as sleeping in separate rooms
and separate beds
i know the argument is that well my
spouse snores i can't sleep
first of all you suffer through that
you that's that's what you've signed up
for
and you can bond in that suffering my
wife complains sometimes because she
claims that i tend to snore i've never
heard myself snore this is her
allegation
and she complains about that sometimes
and i tell her like this is you you
should be
to hear the beautiful noises of my
snoring you should delight in that
you know you should this is a this is a
an amazing opportunity for you every
single night
to lie awake and reflect
about how blessed you are
to to be married to me you know and to
hear the the sweet song that i am that i
am singing in my sleep to you
um
and if you're if there's suffering that
goes through that then you know what
you you are strengthened in that
suffering while i sleep soundly and the
other great thing is that i i that i i
sleep okay and i wake up and i'm fine
and you should take some solace in that
so i've explained that to my wife
she it doesn't really the argument
doesn't resonate with her that well but
that's that's that's the thing and but
also the other thing is
you have to think about uh
symbolism can be important in a marriage
um
wearing a wedding ring is obviously
symbolism
and you could say oh what does a wedding
ring matter well you just take the
wedding ring off you don't need to wear
a wedding ring
it's just it's just a piece of uh
equipment it's just a piece of metal or
whatever on your on your uh
on your hand
yeah but it's it's symbolism it's about
your bond with this other person so you
have to think about if you decide to
take your wedding ring off and go about
your day without it what does that
symbolize what does that choice
symbolize doesn't symbolize anything
good
separating into separate rooms there's a
lot of symbolism there
you're also setting a precedent and part
of the precedent is we have a problem
and we're gonna solve it by separating
and uh once you lay that groundwork
you don't want to see where that leads
so i wouldn't recommend it
as the person who doesn't you know who
sleeps well i don't recommend it
let's get now to the comment section
cory b says matt video games are super
and superhero movies are for 12 year
olds
also matt yay sledding wee
well you know what but it's okay because
i do that with my children that's one of
the advantages of having kids is that
you can do
these uh you can experience these
childlike things again with your kids
even if i continue sliding after they've
gone inside because they're cold still
it's still part of the parenting
experience
so you know if you want to watch
superhero movies like as i as i
said i took my kids to go watch
spiderman
perfectly acceptable it's perfectly
acceptable to take your kids to go watch
a superhero movie um after all the
movies are made for kids
but if you're just an adult you don't
even have kids and you go to watch some
kids movie by yourself or with another
adult
that's weird okay
that's when it becomes an issue all
right so if you if you want an excuse to
watch superhero movies just have kids
perfectly acceptable reason to have kids
tom says just think if only property
owners could vote in local elections any
race religion or sex but only property
owners
what a difference that would make no
vagabonds but only people with a stake
in their communities i love your use of
the word vagabond i think that's not
used
nearly often enough
i understand the property owner argument
the problem is that there are you know
these days there are plenty of people
who are contributing members of their of
society they have jobs they you know
they care for their children they care
for their families and they happen to
rent and so i you know i i don't think
it's necessarily fair to exclude all of
them
and uh as you know for me i would settle
with just a very brief 10 question
civics quiz making sure that
these people have
about the awareness of current events
and how our government works that we
expect of like a fifth grader
and i would settle for that but in my
ideal scenario there would be other
qualifications as well and i do think
that there should be i don't think we
can do a property owner arrangement
because as i said so many people rent um
but
you have to be employed you have to be
earning an income
we could think about you have maybe
maybe only people who have dependents
should be voting
because these are the people that really
have a stake in it
i would consider all of that
all of these possibilities that will
never ever happen in a million years
charlene says i think at the very least
people should be forced to answer a few
basic questions before casting their
vote numerous videos prove the majority
can't name a past president or know the
year of the revolutionary war why should
we trust our country's future in the
hands of people who don't care enough to
learn the most basic things
seems like an obvious point to me
obvious argument now i know that the
counter argument that you always hear is
well who's going to be in charge of
coming up with these tests uh obviously
it'd be a government thing are we going
to trust the government to do this
and yeah i admit that that is a that's a
downside
to a plan like this
but what's the alternative
well the alternative what we're living
through right now
that just any ignoramus any [ __ ] any
person no matter how ignorant someone
who has no idea what's going on
can go in there and cast a vote based on
nothing
so although there are downsides to
a civics quiz scenario and there are
ways that that can be abused
our current scenario our current our
current setup
has many more downsides and can also be
abused and is being abused
think about the way that the government
and the powers that be can abuse the
fact
that stupid ignorant people vote
because government loves it
this is one of the reasons why this plan
will never be put into action
because the people that are in power
right now it doesn't benefit them
if only informed and intelligent people
with a stake in the country are are
voting
the people currently in power right now
they would not be benefited by that and
they know it
it's much better for them to have as
many morons as possible
um
hey what's going on says matt you said
you wouldn't vote for an over 75 year
old yet if it was between trump and a
democrat
wouldn't you vote for the lesser of two
evils i personally don't think desantis
is going to run no i said that i will i
will not support the nomination of
anyone 75 or older
i didn't say that i wouldn't vote for
them i wouldn't that's an important
distinction i wouldn't support the
nomination
so going through the nominating process
in the primaries when i'm looking at all
the options
to me that's a deal breaker
if you're a very elderly person
and uh
you're going to approach or cross into
your 80s while in office i'm not i'm not
going to support your nomination but if
you are nominated then yeah it does
become the lesser to evils thing and i
understand that and i would still vote
but um
how about we just don't put ourselves in
that position let's not put ourselves in
a position where we have to do the
lesser to evils deal
how about nominating someone you could
really be excited about
like ron desantis
lisa says matt okay so if there were a
person who felt that way about kids but
never ever acted in even the most minor
way and was immediately scared and upset
about the feeling
but aside from a feeling this person has
done nothing and ever wants to what
would you suggest to that person or do
you believe it's a choice and no one
feels that way
i am certainly not advocating for them
or normalizing but you knock down a
suggested solution without any other
options do you feel such a person should
deal with it on their own
that religion that religion should make
it go away what's your solution well
there is no solution first of all we
have to we're talking about pedophilia
here uh there's no solution to it in the
sense that we're not going to be able to
do anything
that makes it go away and it's just not
a part we're not going to be able to
erase pedophilia from the world
completely
and uh that's the first thing we have to
do is is realize that
and so now what we're doing is what's
the best way to manage this problem
and the best way to manage it
is to segregate the dangerous people get
them out of society
um the issue of okay you have someone
that you're talking about someone who
has these
this inclination this impulse they've
never acted on it
and i assume you would agree
pornography and all that that counts as
acting on it
because if they've acted on it in any
way
i say send them to prison forever
like act on it one time you're done
forever you're not getting a second
chance
because we know that there's not going
to be any there's never going to be a
point where where you can be where we
can trust that you've been rehabilitated
and you're not a danger to society
anymore you're done forever you're gone
from society
but
in your scenario hypothetically you've
got someone
who has these thoughts
never acted on them in any way
whatsoever never committed any crime at
all
um
you say that i was i was
you know shooting down the suggested
quote-unquote solution in the in the usa
today article i didn't i mean
the author of that article was saying
well people like that we need we
they need to get them into therapy we
need to figure out a way to you know we
need to start
figuring out a way to help them suppress
these feelings and all that
yeah i agree with that
i think everybody would agree with that
my issue with the article is the way
that all that that sentiment was couched
in all this rhetoric about normalizing
and destigmatizing
that we don't want to do
the fact that
pedophilia is stigmatized is a very good
thing
my greatest fear is that it will get to
a point where it's no longer stigmatized
so we we want it to be stigmatized we
don't want it to be treated as a normal
thing
we don't want to talk about you know use
different words minor attracted person
we don't want to talk about them as
though they're a community none of that
so that was my issue with the article
you know with the ever increasing
numbers of cars makes and models and
everything and all all of the stuff
that's out there it's impossible to
stock all the parts you need in a
traditional chain storefront so why
endure the pointless sometimes
intimidating questioning about the
specifications of your vehicle only to
have the guy behind the counter say oh
well we don't have that we got to order
it in you know you could have just cut
out the middleman you could have done it
yourself you have computers at home you
have a one in your pocket with access to
rockauto.com rockauto.com is a family
business serving auto parts customers
online for 20 years go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers the
rockauto.com catalog is unique and very
easy to navigate you can easily quickly
see all the parts available for your
vehicle and choose the brand
specifications and prices that you
prefer best thing of all prices
rockauto.com are reliably low and
they're the same for everybody
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts why spend twice as much for
the same parts and uh and a worse
selection there's no reason to do it go
to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts that are available for your car
truck right walsh in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
so long time fans of this show will
remember that um last week a long time
ago we cancelled trans youtuber samantha
lux who posted a video
attacking my best-selling lgbt novel
johnny the walrus which is available for
pre-order at johnnywalrus.com
after i debunked sam's debunking many
people in the comments informed me that
youtube is in fact full of videos
criticizing my seminal work of
children's literature johnny the walrus
which is available johnnywalrus.com
they wanted to know why i only picked on
good old sam
while leaving these other would-be
debunkers unscathed
well as you know i'm a big advocate for
equity and inclusion i would never want
to single anybody out unfairly or leave
or leave anybody out unfairly and so
today i'm gonna go through
all the other anti-johnny the walrus
videos on the platform and cancel all of
them now we're not gonna have time
unfortunately to watch all these videos
in their entirety but we'll watch a
short and hopefully representative clip
from each just so we get an idea of what
they're all about enough to demonstrate
why they deserve to be canceled some of
these videos are from accounts with lots
of subscribers some of them have a
subscriber base that includes their
immediate families and nobody else
and some probably don't even have a fan
base that large but we're gonna we're
gonna include the whole spectrum today
because i think that's that's the
fairest thing and again this is about
equity
so we begin with the youtube channel
just a lazy gamer
already you can appreciate the
self-awareness at the very least let's
see what lazy gamer has to say about my
book yes matt walsh has decided to make
a book
hating on trans children because you
know you gotta get that hate speech in
when they're young but here's the thing
he's also decided to do the let's go
brandon song bryson gray approach and go
hey
maybe you can get me in the top 10. and
that'll really show if you you give me
your money
and if we go to amazon
he's already got 23 ratings
no verified purchasers of course because
the book hasn't made it to anyone's
store
now this book
is on amazon amazon has rules against
hate speech
in their book they have that in the
rules
and i get the feeling he's hoping
that this book gets banned on amazon to
play the victim even more maybe after
they get it up like number 15 or
whatever on a chart and of course he's
selling signed copies for i think it's
thirty dollars with ten dollar shipping
because of course he is because the
grifting never stops
um okay to begin with
he talks about there's a signed copies
30 for a signed copy is a steal i'm
literally the most prominent and
respected lgbt children's author in
american history as well as the
country's
leading cult leader and the most
generous philanthropist and abuela
fundraiser of the 21st century so my
signature is worth thousands um that i'd
give it away for a measly thirty dollars
just speaks again to my generosity not
to mention my humility
furthermore i i take a great exception
to the claim that we wanted to get
banned from amazon after reaching number
15 on the chart that's absurd
we wanted to get banned after reaching
the top five
we did get to the top five but we didn't
get banned instead we just got banned
from target which was a rather sort of
disappointing
runner-up prize finally the book does
not hate on trans kids
primarily because there's no such thing
as trans kids
my issue is with the adults who have
invented the category of trans kids
so if i'm hating on anyone it's them
because they're morally debased child
abusers hopefully that clears that up
now we have youtuber sam collins sam has
a larger presence on youtube over 800
thousand subscribers let's see what sam
has to offer
and a simple procedure cuts feet into
fins
the doctor wants to cut
into johnny and make him into a walrus
ah there it is the whole mutilation
thing because we chop ourselves up
remember when we have surgeries we're
mutilating ourselves and we're chopping
ourselves up it's also funny because
this book is about a child and i've said
it over and over again and many trans
people have said that children don't get
surgeries we could say it a thousand
times but these people still just choose
not to believe what we say it's really
funny because this can be explained with
just one simple thought children don't
get surgery right how would you ever
have a surgery when you're not fully
developed anyways you can't
cut this off if it's not there so please
explain to me how these children are
getting surgeries
uh happily i'll explain it a few points
here first
no i don't think that when trans people
have surgery they're mutilating
themselves
because if you have a trans person who
has gallbladder surgery
or gets their acl repaired or has heart
surgery
i wouldn't call that mutilation
surgeries that are meant to treat
medical issues are not mutilation no
matter who's getting them
but a surgery that destroys a healthy
body part or that slices open a healthy
organ and flips it inside out
is mutilation no matter who's getting it
by definition that's mutilation now if
you don't believe me let's go to the
dictionary mutilation here's the the
definition an act or instance of
destroying removing or severely damaging
a limb or other body part of a person or
animal
so what happens to the penis during a
sex chain surgery
what happens to a woman's breasts during
top surgery
these parts of the body are either
removed or destroyed
they are by definition mutilated
there's no denying this
now as for the claim that children don't
get these procedures that is for one
thing a lie
minor girls do in fact have their
breasts removed it's very common happens
all the time minor boys have even had
their penises mutilated that also
happens
but even if that weren't happening
still children are being conditioned to
make those choices quote unquote later
on in life they're being put on that
path even though they don't understand
the path they're on
and even if most boys aren't being
physically altered through surgery they
are being given puberty blockers like
lupron which is chemical castration
the same drug used to chemically
castrate sex offenders so your argument
sam is that the boys aren't being
surgically castrated they're just being
chemically castrated
and even that argument as insane as it
is
is also factually wrong
the truth is that both things are
happening
now we turn to a youtuber just justin
freakin the guy's uh you know he's a
formidable voice in the culture he has
uh 6 000 subscribers averages easily
over 30 views per video and his channel
description promises quote uncensored
and unfiltered political talk and debate
from a leftist perspective the day's top
news stories and videos with astute
social commentary
i'm not sure if we can trust the part of
the social the part about you know
astute social commentary i don't know
about that we'll find out in a minute
but we can be confident that it's
uncensored
if this guy's a leftist then certainly
we can be assured that he has not been
censored so let's bring let's see what
he brings to the table
not as insane as matt walsh from the
daily wire releasing a children's book
here is matt walsh apparently
getting some children together
for story hour
with sweet baby matt walsh
okay
hello boys and girls yeah the kids look
about as enthused as we are he didn't
draw the
cartoons and that's the main part of the
book
like
passing yourself off as the author of
this stupid book is insane because you
know what this book is this book is a
actual talented illustrator
and then some dumb words on top of it
honestly i don't know why this guy
doesn't get more views i mean he's like
macho man randy savage
if macho man randy savage
uh could only bench press 45 pounds
and was a hippie
but randy has exposed a startling truth
that i did not illustrate my own
children's book i have tried to keep
this hidden
by putting the illustrator's name on the
cover i was hoping to hide it in plain
sight and my plan almost worked until
seth rogen's unemployed cousin foiled
the plot
um all right let's finish this up with a
somewhat larger account this is uh val
shervash i don't know how to pronounce
his name 386 thousand subscribers his
video is titled matt walsh reads his new
anti-trans book to kids and i am
incredibly uncomfortable and the video's
done pretty well for us got nearly 150
000 views let's skip ahead to i think
what is i guess the crux of his argument
against my book
wait what is the lesson at the wait so
wait now is he bird gender wait what is
the
what does any of this mean
what does any of this mean man
uh no he said earlier people online told
his mom a well-meaning mother was duped
by evil transgender sj that was yeah
yeah okay but like what about the kid
like the kid didn't seem after the kids
said i am a walrus
and had a picture taken of him the kid
had no input whatsoever did the kid want
to eat the worms if not why didn't he
stop what was was the kid like i don't
want to eat the worms and the mom was
like no you have to the people on
instagram said that you have to or i'm a
bit like
i i i don't want to dig into this too
hard because it's obviously really
stupid but i am genuinely astounded by
the incompetence with which this was put
together like they paid an artist they
had it published like it's on sale like
how do you not put a little more effort
not even just the quality of the art but
like the language used betrays such an
incredible incompetence in using
allegory to deliver a political message
that's true i'm not good with language i
mean we can't all be wordsmiths like
valshar who says things like the
language used betrays such an incredible
incompetence in using allegory to
deliver a political message
dude why do you speak in real life like
you're a ninth grader writing a book
report and trying to hit a minimum word
count
you think it's a bad allegory just say
that
though i'm not sure how you could judge
the competence of the story or the
allegory considering you by you're on a
mission don't understand the point
you're a grown adult who failed to grasp
the extremely simple message in a
rhyming children's book written on
cardboard for preschoolers
and somehow you think that your failures
of reading comprehension are an
embarrassment to me
i mean i am embarrassed watching this
but the embarrassment is of the second
hand variety i assure you
the good news is that
you seem to have almost understood the
point so you got to the 10 yard line
intellectually before you fumble the
mental football
you nearly made it all the way there
because you note how in the story the
mom is the focus while the child johnny
has little input
into his own alleged lifestyle choice
he's doing things he's walking down a
certain path but it doesn't really seem
like he's choosing to go in that
direction
yes vaush that's the point
that that's exactly the point
that's what we're going for
the fact that johnny's mommy is really
the main character
in a story that's ostensibly about
johnny himself is not an accident
that's a bit of intentional irony
very much an intentional creative
decision
by the brilliant author of this book
which is available at johnnywalrus.com
it's almost as if
i'm trying to make the point
that transgenderism among children is
once again an event in invention of the
adults around them no child can actually
choose this path they don't have the
psychological and emotional formation
required to make an informed decision
about fundamentally altering their
identities
any child therefore who does make such a
decision decision quote unquote has been
by definition pushed and pulled that way
by the grown-ups in their lives
do you understand now
because i literally can't make it any
simpler or plainer than that
the book is written at a reading level
for kids who barely know how to read
so if that's still above your
intellectual pay grade i'm afraid
there's not much else i can do
except say
that you're canceled
along with fake randy savage sam collins
the rest of the youtube hordes who have
all tried and failed to take down my
book johnny the walrus which is
available for sale at johnnywalrus.com
we'll leave it there for today thanks
for watching thanks for listening have a
great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens production manager pablo
vadowsky the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022
tom cotton trolls chuck schumer on the
floor of the u.s senate donald trump
attacks ron desantis and the local
satanic temple hosts an after-school
club in a midwestern elementary school
check it out on the michael knoll show